[Music]
it's that time again another week of Kos
and who was that special lady we have in
the background and I love it and Selina
Kyle aka the Catwoman now over the years
we have gotten a ton of cat women in the
movies and on TV and you know for me
only two of them stand out
I don't even count the DC EU versions of
Catwoman you know the Michelle fight for
the Halle Berry's none of those can
never hold a candle to like onyx Eartha
Kitt and Julie Newmar
the kid Julian they can't hold a candle
to these iconic women who played the
role of Catwoman em in the TV show and
you know the movies just never captured
the essence of the character but the
books did
now um I don't usually like what powers
do chef Kevin is not a metahuman she's
just a regular woman who they try to say
that she's a little intuitive with cats
but she's never seen her like being able
to control lions and black panthers and
animals of that nature so she's just a
cat lady but she is highly adapt to
stealth plus she has good hand to hand
combat
she learned by two top-notch fighters in
the DC Universe I believe a wildcat is
one from the Justice Society he's an
accomplished boxing so she can hold her
own with people in her weight class
other women and you know guys probably
if they fighting skills aren't as good
but she's not really a hand-to-hand
combat you know she's more or less and
you know stealth she wants to get in get
out steal the jewels
but we all know the love affair that she
has with Batman the give and take you
know on the TV show we definitely had to
watch you know our Batman you know share
a kiss hair in there and he's trying to
convert her because you know Batman he's
a playboy you understand
under that gruff tough exterior he's
still the playboy philanthropist mm-hmm
billionaire you know so and she actually
you know sings to those as harmonies in
his soul
so they both are your face is the same
coin you know so that's why they
gravitate towards each other you know
she doesn't really cause any harm you
know you can't really say she's out had
killing people or doing anything she
steals from the rich why because she
wants to live a lavish lifestyle you
know she comes from modest upbringing so
that's the synapses oh yeah
and her Batman like supposed to was
supposed to get married in the books
yeah that was doing a whole bunch of
books with her and Batman leading up to
it and all this stuff and she left you a
boy at the altar
yes she couldn't commit but hey what cat
really commits today on a tell the truth
but check it out
we're about this statue right here this
is prime and I mean hope excuse me I got
the prime ones Premium Format statue on
my mind because it just came up for
pre-order now I could have pre-order
that one because I believe I have the
definitive one the sideshow Catwoman as
you can see she's in full latex from
head to toe
this Premium Format is exclusive it
comes with to switch out heads this is
one and this is other it also come with
two off hands like cuz the one hand that
she uses holds the whip that goes around
her body and then she has in one hand
like after she just did a heist she has
a bag of emeralds and diamonds inside
the bag and in the other hand is just
open flare hand so when you get the
exclusive
I believe the exclusive comes with the
bag of emeralds or whatever that's in
there
and you know you got the little cat the
little Catholics nice you know um I
noticed when I took a flash the eyes
glow um so like I said this is a
fantastic statue this is a must-have for
any Batman fan who definitely want to
display
you know his love interest or any
supreme you know fan of latex because
this is mixed-media remember what I told
you guys about mixed-media mixed-media
is material on top of the resident
statue so this is mixed-media it goes
anywhere from I think it opened at 399
you can probably get it eBay for a
thousand dollars now it's a highly
sought after statute and if you happen
to have it you know it's great the base
is beautiful you see all the lion heads
that surrounded all of them look
fantastic
and she's on like a pavement you can see
the the rocks and stuff it looks really
nice is a great base accentuated by a
great statue a dynamic pose and it's
highlighted with the cat
now you know what time it is is the time
when I tell you guys the life following
subscribe and also go to the Lords of
gaming net where you can get all the
information on the new Kos the new
combat talk with the King and the last
word with Lord kognito and Atlantis and
also episodes iron Lords podcast where
this guy's at and we talk about all the
video games and all the news and talk
about all the trade shows that goes on
so make sure that you go to Lourdes
gamer dotnet and put on that icon so it
can definitely tell you when new
information comes out because we have
some great articles up right as I speak
but stick around so I can give you this
statute in all its glory and next week
we might see somebody
it's a little bit hard to kill Hey when
BK Oh as if I gave you the answers the
week before see you next week
[Music]
[Music]